austin gomper who has pitched well this
year hopes to pick up his first win as a
rocky this afternoon mccormick in the
lead-off spot today with miles straw not
in the lineup
pitch breaking ball strike three called
backdoor knuckle curve
out number one for gombert
so one out of no one on for left fielder
michael brantley hitting 327 365 on base
percentage two homers and four runs
batted in for brantley 1-2 pitch
hits sharply left side diving stop story
gets to his feet long throwing got him
cold or not the defensive excellence of
trevor's story remains constant it's
jose urquini on the mound for the
houston astros today and her kitty made
his big league debut in coors field and
a four and a half era in three starts
rocky's trying to strike early
trevor's story
one for four last night with a run
scored 1-0 treble rip it
fair just inside the third baseline
it'll roll down onto the track topia
scores they're going to sand mcmahon
he'll score from first ball loose trev
trying to get the third
is tagged down a two-run double for
story
so two outs now and the batter will be
cj crone the first baseman
five rbi night for cj
last night
fifth time he has done that in his
career
two strike pitch again and that's a
ground ball left side deep in the hole
backhanded by correa down on one knee
one hop throw was in time to retire
krone excellent play by carlos correa
and the inning comes to an end a rough
start for kitty the first three rockies
reach including stories two run double
and after one rocky's two astros number
and now it's julie guriel's turn with
one out
and one oh on
julie
he's pulled off a little bit over his
last 11. still eighth in the al with a
339 average third with a 464 on base
percentage a home run and five rbis for
euler first pitch and yuli drives this
one pretty deep to left it sends back
tapia still going back looking up see a
lighter
a two-run home run for yuley guriel and
the game is tied at two
yulie's second home run of the season
jonathan dasa will lead off the rocky's
second urkidi shakes off the sign now
the 2-2 is hit well down the left field
line hooking towards the corner but it
is gone
touch them all time
yada then dazza
his first of the year
and the rockies promptly regain the lead
three to two
first career home run for daza
a no doubter to left to give the rockies
the lead
now dom nunez stands in the catcher
batting 210 games 273 on base percentage
four homers and seven rbis
for noon yet starting
behind the plate for the second straight
game in this series
urkiti the 2-2 and it's lined into
center field for a base hit
home comes garrett hampson
rbi number eight for dom nunez
4-2 colorado so two out nunez at third
rocky's with a four to two lead in the
bottom of the second ryan mcmahon at the
plate he singled in the first came
around the score
pitch on the way and mcmahon pops this
one up on the infield bregman cutting
across on the grass between second and
the mound and he makes the catch to
retire the side rockies get two more
dazza homers nunez an rbi single and
we're through two innings
rockies four astros two
throwing the batter krone smashed one to
shortstop correa made a terrific play to
get him
four to two rockies in the home third
krone grounded out his first time up
hits the ball hard to straight away
center field now towards right
diving catch by kyle tucker
kyle tucker coming out of nowhere in
right field
making a diving catch in right center
field one of the plays of the year for
the astros
yeah that's going to be on quick pitch
later trust me
so here's garrett hampson
who doubled
down the left field line his first time
absent has scored 13 runs to lead the
rockies
4-6-0 for the rockies 2-1-0 for the
astros here's the pitch
fastball hit in the air
and hampson has hit it out to center
shallow here's mccormick coming in
tucker moves in front of him good
running catch by tucker who made two
excellent plays
one of them a definite beauty here in
the third inning so it's no runs one hit
two men left after three rockies four
astros two
dom nunez rbi single back in the second
inning
grounded out to guriel the first baseman
in the fourth we're in the last to the
sixth rockies lead it 4-2
pitch to nunez is hit towards left
center field that's going to be a base
hit that's going to score garrett
hampson
nunez thinking two on the slide he's in
there with a double
rbi two bagger for dom nunez
i think that young man starting to enjoy
being in the big leagues 5-2 rockies
and back to the top of the orders the
rockies try and build what at the moment
is a three-run advantage
rymel tapia 0-4-2 with a walk and a run
scored
b-lag's pitch to him is hit the
left-center field moving over mccormick
he'll make the catch nunez tags he will
score
rymel tapia
sacrifice flies 6-2 rockies
and now they're loaded up for charlie
blackmon
here's the 1-0
and blackman lines this one to right
back is tucker he's there to make the
catch and the inning is over hit well by
blackman but tucker was well positioned
the rockies score a couple to pad their
lead
and we're through six innings in
colorado rocky's six astros two
one out of the ninth rockies lead six to
two and giriel coming to the plate
flurries continue to pick up
first pitch to yuli ground ball left
side to his right story he's got it long
throw to first just in time to get yuli
a run comes home as correa scores to
make it six to three colorado
oledmiss diaz will be the batter
another one two
quickly off the mound low throw handled
it first by krone to end the ball game
cj with a nice pickup and the rockies
win it six to three
and for just the second time this year
they've won consecutive ball games
and they sweep the mini two-game set
with a very talented houston astros team
austin gomberg congratulations he was
marvelous today he gets his first
victory in iraqis uniform